il prend place près de la mairie de ben
deux mercredis par mois
le bus de la pmi le service de
protection maternelle et infantile une
compétence du département
il est équipé de deux cabinets destiné
aux parents et aux enfants de 0 à 6 ans
comme yacine 18 mois j'ai pris le choix
d'aller dans un centre pmi par rapport
aussi autant qu'ils prennent avec
l'enfant parce que quand on va chez un
pédiatre on sait très bien que c'est un
rendez-vous un quart d'heure une
demi-heure il faut aller assez vite vite
ce bus reçoit en moyenne 17 fallu par
jour des consultations gratuites
assurées par un médecin généraliste et
une infirmière puéricultrice leur
développement psychomoteur leur
croissance
les vaccins si nécessaire dans l'examen
clinique les vaccins si nécessaire les
prescriptions également s'il ya besoin
notamment une vitamine et puis dépôt des
petites les petits tracas quotidiens
nous avons également un rôle sur
l'accompagnement parental dans le
développement de l'enfant les questions
sur l'alimentation sur le sommeil sur
qu'est ce que l'enfant fait au quotidien
si jouer ses occupations
le bus a été lancé il y a deux ans il
fait partie du grand plan de
restructuration lancé en 2015 par le
département l'avantagent de du bus c'est
que c'est très souple donc rester souple
et on peut très bien se dire là il ya un
besoin plus important parce qu'il ya
plus de deux moments et plus de
naissances et on peut très bien créer
une halte selon les selon les besoins
pendant six mois un an deux ans on ne
fait pas de curatif c'est elle en fait
on est on est sur le conseil me soit
prévention mais on ne fait pas de
curative c'est-à-dire un enfant malade
on va pas venir un permis pour une
prescription pour ce genre de choses
aujourd'hui 24 centres de pmi sont
implantés dans les yvelines
comme celui de guyancourt déménager dans
des locaux plus grands et inauguré en
novembre 2018 lorsque ces centres qui
étaient parfois ouverts qu'une demi
journée ou demi journée par semaine puis
s'être ouvert du lundi matin au vendredi
soir de façon visible pour que les
mamans qui ont nombreuses qui on avait
besoin puissent accéder facilement
dix communes se sont portées candidates
pour accueillir le bus depuis le 4 mars
une onzième les a rejoint
magny les hameaux est une nouvelle étape
mensuel les yvelines voit naître chaque
année vingt mille nourrisson